pouvoir démarrer quelque
de concret
le concret
de la pratique de des sports et
notamment les personnes en situation de
handicap dans les clubs valides aux
bénéfices en fait de cette opération si
vous permettre aux personnes handicapées
de dar gérer les clubs valides que ce
soit dans n'importe quel sport ce petit
de l'athlétisme où ça peut être du tir à
la chapelle du foot c'est peut être de
la natation de buts si vous intégrez par
me parler des personnes valides et de
leur montrer qu'on est tout à fait
capable de faire comme la cette
opération permet d'acquérir du matériel
mais il faut aussi penser à aussi attelé
mais les entraîneurs qui font soigner à
atelier à
les personnes en situation de handicap
quelle que soit en fait le handicap les
compagnons du mans second était
sollicité par le conseil départemental
et par le représentant de
la pf pour faire une présentation de
notre discipline et qui discipline qui
accueille 2
des handicaps de tous styles les
personnes en fauteuil
des handicaps légers il ya l'association
montjoie qui
kylie coach jusqu'à des handicaps bénin
qui nécessite pas forcément de
deux fauteuils ou deux
le matériel dédié depuis toujours on a
fait le choix comme l'a expliqué
monsieur christian dréan même
d'accueillir des personnes en situation
d'handicap des handicaps de tous types